the death toll from germany's
devastating flood disaster has risen to
more than 160
as emergency workers continue to search
for dozens of people still
unaccounted for some experts say it was
a failure of germany's flood warning
system that led to such widespread
devastation they say authorities knew
what was coming
but failed to prepare
among the many questions these floods
have left in their wake
is one about the warnings did people
understand that lives were in danger
from heavy rainfall
those who were there say information was
chaotic
a fire service vehicle came through but
you couldn't understand what they were
saying
i asked a neighbour he said we should
turn off the electricity
because water was coming but nobody
realized it would be a flood more than
two meters high
there were advanced warnings about heavy
rain and so on but some of the warnings
were wrong
they told us there was another flood
coming so we went up the hill
but there was nothing as invalid
but the head of the national disaster
response agency visiting the region on
monday
said the system had worked well
our warning system worked in each and
every case the german weather service
the flood centers and the local
authorities
made intensive use of it 150 warning
signals were sent by
our system
some of those warnings were sent out
using phone apps
but a nationwide test of the system in
2020
showed that does not always work some
warnings came through
half an hour late germany also has a
more old-fashioned network of
sirens from cold war days many of these
have been dismantled in recent years
but around fifteen thousand are still in
operation
yet even such a simple technology is not
foolproof
they sound the siren once every month
but not when something like this happens
i don't understand
it in view of so many deaths it's not
surprising
some people are demanding changes but
for now
the main task is to clean up and to
begin
to learn the lessons
our reporter julia sardelli is on the
ground covering the latest developments
she joins us from the town of antana
in the german state of
rhineland-palatinate which was
especially hard hit
by the flooding
so julia what is the situation there
today
yes it's going to be another day of
cleaning up for the residents here and
for the volunteers who came to help
the lower part of town here behind me
that which is along the river has been
completely destroyed
a road has been swept away a bus over
here has
landed on the shore so the amount of
devastation is really astounding
and one has to imagine that so many
towns like this one have
an equally high level of destruction so
the tragedy is really widespread here in
the region and it's not just a tragedy
of destruction of objects it's
also the loss of human life so here in
the state of rhineland-palatinate 117
people have been
found dead so far many are still missing
and unfortunately the authorities expect
the death toll to to rise still while
while they're
they are clearing up the sellers and the
destroyed homes and they expect to find
more bodies
so cleanup efforts are underway there
but i understand many residents in the
area
are still enduring tough conditions tell
us more about that
yes many people here have lost
everything they have lost their home
they have lost their livelihoods because
restaurants
shops hotels have all been destroyed and
many people are very worried for their
immediate future also in economic terms
but even the people who are lucky and
whose homes are still intact
have a hard time living here there's no
electricity there's no gas
there's no water so it's really hard to
charge one's phone
to wash up after the cleanup or even to
find the functioning toilet
now we heard some angry voices in that
report just a moment ago
people saying they were given
insufficient warning
about this blood are authorities
considering any changes to the warning
system as a result of this disaster
well what we've heard until now is both
federal and local
authorities saying that their prevention
warning system worked that they did send
out warnings to the population and that
they
knew that this was coming they said
there might be some lessons to be
learned but now is not the moment to
be looking at that but here on the
ground speaking to people
it feels like the communication was at
least spotty
some people said the firemen came and
warned them and they ran to the hills
others said the firemen came too late
and there was nowhere for them to go
while others really didn't really grasp
the extent of the flooding that was
about to hit them
julia thank you very much for your
reporting that was julia saudelli there
in
altanar our reporter emily gordeen is on
the ground covering the latest
developments she joins us now from the
town of sure now
in the southern german state of bavaria
so emily what's the situation where you
are today
so right now we're in an area that was
evacuated in light of the floods on
saturday
and now what you see behind me is people
tidying up you can see behind me here on
my right
is um the mud that came down from the
hill together with the flood
literally reached until the windowsills
here and you can see
diggers trying to to free the area of
the mud that came down
you can see that the relief agency the
federal relief agency the thw
working in line with um with the local
fire brigade
and even if you look on my left here now
what you will see as well is that the
military the local the from the local
base here came as well to help to dig
the gardens and and what people had you
know out of the mud
so it's really it's a very tense
situation
um people are still can't quite come to
terms with what has happened because
this is extreme
and um you know and at the same time
it's all hands on deck people are
are you know um distributing little
sandwiches to
to you know to thank the helpers that
are here so
it is intense but people are
trying to really just get on with it now
the flooding
did claim lives in bavaria i understand
but not nearly as many as in neighboring
states
was that just a matter of luck or the
result of better
disaster preparedness
well i spoke with a leader here of the
local fire brigade and he said that
it also comes down to just being a bit
of a scaredy cat as soon as they
hear uh of a big torrential rain then
they um immediately you know they act
um but also he said that it has to do
with the settlement structure here right
so this area where we're in right now
has about 20 to 30 houses and then there
comes nothing for a while and then you
have again settlements of 20 to 30
houses so
the extent is going to be smaller and at
the same time what you need to know here
is that
this is still an extraordinary situation
this is we're standing here
at the at the cusp of a hill of a
mountain really
and um what you what you you know
usually
if there's like a little a little stream
coming down the hill you know that'll
then be bigger and turn into a flood
really but
this mountain here doesn't even have a
really big you know a stream where you
could say oh we can expect more rain to
come down here so
you if you look at to my right here
where the mud is and everything this is
where this huge stream must have come
down and it because of the torrential
rain you know because it was so strong
it took with it um little rocks and
everything debris
with it so it really turned into this
this must like
sort of flood to go that landslide so it
is really quite extraordinary what's
happened here
and just briefly emily um there's been
massive
loss of property there destruction of
property people have
lost their homes or livelihoods what
kind of
help can they expect from authorities
well i mean on the federal level they
have promised to to
put up to 300 million euros um
you know in relief but that is for all
of germany so not just for bavaria
bavaria itself has promised about 50
million
so there is help but at the same time
you know floods aren't necessarily
uncommon in this area
um the big issue that was dealt with a
few years ago or that came up is
you know how much does the state pay and
how much should people prepare for it
um in terms of insurance and some of the
help that that is being put forward from
the state is also
you know dependent on whether people
have insurance but if you're living in a
in a flood prone area then your
insurance is going to be extremely high
and not everyone can afford it and in
some even
some areas even it's the question of
will insurances even put up with the
risk
so that's the question that needs to be
solved in the future
emily thank you very much dw's emily
gordeen there reporting from chernow
bavaria
and joining us now from luxembourg is
jeff decosta he's a researcher focusing
on flood warning systems at the
university of redding
thanks for being with us so german
authorities
insist their flood warnings worked even
though there was
massive loss of life what's your
assessment did the warning system
function the way it was intended
well um thank you for this great
question
uh actually if we look at the aftermath
of last week's disaster um it is quite
evident that the warning systems were
not successful
in the way that um maybe the german
authorities would have hoped that they
would have been
um so i do think um there are some
there are certain uh problems with the
ways that um
this crisis was dealt with and the
warning systems were not
effectively issued okay so there
are problems there you say what lessons
then do you think
should be learned from this disaster
when it comes to flood warnings
i mean there should be a coordinated
effort and
a clear transmission line between the
warnings given by scientists and the
decisions that are taken by decision
makers underground
this is a problematic that is not
specific to germany but it is
a worldwide phenomenon some countries
deal with it better than others
but in this crisis we have clearly seen
that this is not a localized phenomenon
and it's really important that now we
come together and try to find ways
in how we can protect ourselves and
prevent further such outcomes or even
worse
you've been personally affected i
understand by events as your family home
in luxembourg was flooded can you tell
us a bit more about what happened there
absolutely um it came well
my parents called me very late at night
they were very distressed
and i went there as fast as i could and
as safely as i could to help them build
water out
but it was it was a sad scene to see i
mean it was my childhood home
all the memories submerged underwater
and just to see how emotionally draining
it is also for flood victims
is a sad reminder of just how
devastating floods are uh on people
and societies as a whole can you tell us
in a situation like this how the flood
system the flood warning system
is supposed to work i mean assuming that
the
those who were monitoring conditions
actually knew what was coming
was is it how is that supposed to be
communicated to the people on the ground
to get them
out of harm's way
thank you so um there are um
flood warnings in place that are
european but
also local authorities like weather
services for instance in germany as well
that issued warnings
uh that were just as accurate as the
pan-european warning system
and notification system apologies and
the thing is it's not just about the
warning but also about the preparedness
and how resilient the population is
in terms of the vulnerabilities that
they have and the exposure
to risk that they have this is an
assessment that needs to be made
and the decisions need to be taken
according to to these vulnerabilities
based on the warnings that decision
makers get and it shouldn't be up to
them
to decide whether a situation is
dangerous
for their inhabitants or for the
citizens of that particular place
in order to make a wise decision about
to evacuate or not to evacuate people
need to be prepared there needs to be an
educational part
in which people know exactly what to do
in case of a crisis
because as we all know when there is an
emergency situation
people do not react rationally so
especially if something comes as a
surprise um people
need to have this sort of knowledge
beforehand
sort of like a fire drill if you will we
all train
um for a fire drill in case of an
emergency
so that we know do in case panic strikes
we know exactly
what we have to do and this is sadly not
the case
not just here but everywhere across
europe and
beyond i think there's going to be a lot
more discussion about this uh
coming jeff decosta from the university
of redding thank you very much
thank you very much for having me